I am Dita Von Teese and I am known for
being a burlesque performer but I am now
also a lingerie designer for me my
relationship with lingerie has always
been about seduction of self my
fascination and obsession with lingerie
started at a very young age I watch a
lot of old movies with my mother I was
always fascinated by the lingerie that I
got sneak peeks of and my first job was
working in a lingerie store I feel like
women are more adventurous now like
they're willing to try new things and
especially with my collection originally
I did a few things kind of safe and then
when we started throwing in the really
risque pieces the women really responded
to it and that makes me very pleased
well it wasn't always easy for me in the
course of my career you know I walked
into a strip club in 1991 and you know
it was all blonds and rock and roll
music and neon bikinis and I could have
walked in and said oh I don't belong
here I'm not like them but I walked in
and thought like yeah there's no one
like me here I'm gonna win you know when
I first started making the shows and
posing for risque pinups and that sort
of thing it was kind of taboo and risque
and you know burlesque traditionally in
the 30s and 40s was entertainment geared
toward men
but now what you have in the neo
burlesque movement is women that are
becoming inspired by the art of creation
and and the confidence that they find in
seeing a burlesque show or performing a
burlesque show we're not afraid anymore
of really owning our sensuality
you know I'm 41 now and I'm very happy
to like you know shift from striptease
burlesque shows to building my brand and
really staying focused on something that
I think I stand for
[Music]